da madonna jetzt einen wegpunkt
unendliche wasserquelle und melonen fast
schon abgehakt das heißt dass schmutz
noch eben holen als überhaupt hier
das fühlt sich schon wieder sollen als
wäre das hier wieder komplett woanders
an den das war darum die ecke stimmt ich
bin noch nicht sicher ob wir in die
richtige richtung laufen also ob wir
hier wirklich noch mal auf eine zweite
wasserquelle stoßen
bz wer immer schon das wasser oder
stimmen das wasser ist er bei der oase
auch dann haben wir die quelle auch
schon das ist ja geil
ok wartet da gehe ich glaube ich muss
hier rein weil dort grenzt daran dass
das nicht so sein soll dir du ich mal
wieder einfach
herber verstehe ich jetzt nicht warum
jetzt hier und so ich verstehe jetzt
gerade nicht warum das loch war
das muss eigentlich etwas heiß oder was
ist einfach in wien fällt mir die fackel
müssen vorsichtig mit unserer kohle
umgehen
naja gut um es noch mal hin wo war das
noch mal habe ich schon wieder verlaufen
hier hinter war das glaube ich
da wackelt in die hand los geht's darum
immer noch fackel der super direkt mal
ist hier gelassen der können wir mal ein
paar sit links hier geben
oder habe ich davon welchen er mich
nicht weil ich will mir auch so einen
coolen baum der bauen
ich will auch seine coole palme kann
sein dass hier nicht rauskommen dass mit
der hand ab wonach film jedoch kaum so
gut sind sind normale egal wie hoch
wer
ja
ob
so meine lieben freunde jetzt wird noch
spannender denn nun entdecken wir nicht
mehr sondern wir können jetzt endlich
bei
wir freuen uns alle gut tut mir leid
dass ich allgemein jetzt so in dieser
folge und auch in der letzten folge
wahrscheinlich in der nächsten folge ein
wenig anders bin und nein das da hinten
ist kein wasser das hat sich einfach nur
generiert also noch nicht generiert zu
wissen ich bin ein wenig anders warum
bist du anders ich bin total krank oder
das wieder unsere tollen weg punkt der
uns immer zeigt wo wir hin müssen weil
wir das ja auch so gar nicht wissen
soweit der unendliche wasserquelle und
melonen formen und einer dinge zwar
müssen wir auch noch mal ein paar kinder
nach du scheiße und wie kommen wir
pumpkins auch wieder so eine sache
naja müssen wir hinkriegen ich noch mal
kurz eine unendliche quelle hier so dann
haben wir jetzt noch etliche quelle sind
wir alle zufrieden hier kommission
generator sollte auch noch weiterhin
funktionieren fällt nur irgendwie voll
auf den lover aber das sollte nicht
weiter stören weil wir das komplette was
ich bauen möchte aus dingsbums bauer aus
enstone aber die hohe muss sich holen
das stimmt das recht der das wir gerade
gesagt hat
durch david byrd und ich mache ich auch
direkt noch zusammen
papa ist da jetzt was erst man fast gar
nicht gott ist das café am berg noch
mehr ich glaub wir haben knochen
mehreren kann ich nämlich direkt da
zeugen jehova manuellen zwei gut warte
was sonst noch so eine kiste dann können
wir uns ja eigentlich auch schon um die
dinge zu kümmern um die monster falle
und zwar kommt die dorthin ist mit
sicherheit schon aufgefallen
hier habe ich natürlich schon direkt
angefangen natürlich nicht mit der
intention sofort dass ich eine monster
falle hinter wurde ähnliches aber kann
ja alles noch kommen
funkel wiederum
ich mache jetzt mal einfach so gang an
der seite ihr werdet schon sehen also
ich mach das kann alle spontan müsste
wissen
dabei werdet schon auf ok kaputt wie
gesagt alles spontan neue spitzhacke
haben dann eigentlich noch stein hoffe
ich doch
ich brauche auf jeden fall was zu essen
auf
apfel lecker sonst noch was brot so
stein 13 schaufel nämlich auch noch eine
mit sticks und zwei sie auch ganz
brillant findet bis irgendwer ganz
atemberaubend tropf mit den arten dass
wir hier noch nicht gelungen ist haben
gechattet es so oft dass oft dass vor
allem luca deutsch gelernt bei oder du
hast
wir hatten ja schon bei sky blog
manchmal gechattet und so weiter und so
fort
das heißt dass mit den eher gezockt habe
das haben wir hier noch gar nicht
gemacht hat finde ich ganz interessant
ganz cool und ich bin mir noch nicht
sicher ob die monster wirklich nur hier
unten spawn können oder halt doch oben
in seinem gebiet gab ich muss jetzt
einfach mal unten weil ich finde und
eine viel bessere kulisse dass man
wirklich wenn man etr will nach unten
geht und so finde ich eigentlich cooler
die warte moment wo habe ich den gang
gemacht hab ich den hab ich den habe ich
den habe ich den ja okay gut moment
hattest du nachricht schreiben kann hat
erst einmal ganz kurz erklären und zwar
kumpel von mir als wunderkammer
ich hab das jetzt mal im weg gemacht
kumpel von mir zeichnen playstation 3
gekauft playstation 3 besser konsole wie
ich finde aber entscheidet selber was
ihr wollt habe ich auch schon mal gesagt
ich will ja gar nicht beeinflussen
und er hat jetzt fragen an mich von
wegen lps endete ab 18 und alles und
jetzt muss ich ihm damit allen sachen
helfen und so weiter und naja ist für
mich eine ganz blöde arbeitet egal weil
ich gerne hat halt ne ps3 wisse was ich
baue das hier wieder zu ziemlich egal
ich würde sagen wir wollen mich hier
schon die dinge sind diese spawn teile
840 wieder eine monster falle übrigens
was wir gerade auffällt wir können die
eigentlich auch viel einfacher bauen und
zwar viel viel weiße gehalt 44 oder
machen wir die regeln wolle lediglich
bau das jetzt aber dann müssen wir das
erhielten eso fertig machen und zwar
habe ich gehört dass man monster auf
eine bestimmte höhe müssen die müssen
hier unter uns schon wieder kaputt
die müssen runter fallen und dann
irgendwie bei blau weiß ich ja nicht 22
da brennt irgendwas ach du scheiße 83
liegewiese brennt dann mein baum ab
wieso brennt mein baum du heilige ich
suppe ach so wegen der labor alter die
stellt sich auf die mathilde direkt
wieder pennen gehn eben mal eben
nebenbei eben neue spitze gemacht
also was ich gehört habe war einfach
dass man achtet aber ich war früher noch
ein game und 1 abbilder von die familie
gemacht
er ist jetzt ein schönes bilde hier habe
ich schon ich finde euro habe ich schon
hat man was ich gehört habe ist dass
wenn mops 23 122 berg runter fallen dass
man sie dann nur noch einmal schlagen
muss und dann sind sie quasi direkt tot
und dann kriegt man aber auch noch ep
und das möchte ich einfach mal machen
und ich mach das jetzt einfach mal mit
20 betten und dann müssen wir einfach
mal schauen was dabei rumkommt dass die
quasi oben spontan hierunter fallen und
sich dann ihr unten drin sammeln dann
kann ich einfach wieder panschen und
warum euch dass das so lange raus ich
weiß es nicht
während theoretisch steigen die kisten
hinstellen oder somit den drop sachen
ich glaube viel weiter gehe ich jetzt
auch gar nicht rein
ich will halt dass jeder mitte nachher
sollen sollen so ein teil steht wo ich
quasi darum gehen kann wo die drin wo
die quasi runterfallen sage ich mal
also dann irgendwie hier macht man
jedoch für falsch
ja hier ungefähr dass hier quasi so
runter fallen und dann muss ich dir
einfach nur noch einmal schlagen und
dann hat sich das wenn ihr so ungefähr
versteht was männer so dann haben wir da
quasi den runter falsch 8
im moment und hierdurch schlage ich die
dann so immer so gut haben wir zwei
blöcke 34
ach du scheiße da kommt noch mehr gl st
amber 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20 21 was ich dann spawn
die hier oben bewegen sich ja dann nicht
gefallen sie dann runter genau hier ist
jetzt natürlich für euch erstmal so
helfert board of film kann ich also erst
mal nur so als alibi ich baue nur kacke
das heißt man kann nicht sagen was ist
das schön wieder dafür ein kack das ist
einfach alles kacke ja das müsste
eigentlich so über mich wissen
ich will einfach dass ich hier so am
rand ordnen und dann quasi sogar
einlaufen ich weiß auch gar nicht wie
viel sparen fläche die benötigen ob ich
das gerade hier vielleicht alles ein
bisschen übertreiben oder ob ich dann
einfach da so einen fetten kanister sah
ich meine luft bauen wo die dann
letztendlich einfach runterfallen
natürlich man jetzt noch schöner machen
können dort kann immer sagen
bzw wird man natürlich auch machen
könnte wäre es doch was mir grad
überlegen das ist total doof einfach nur
das einfach ignorieren den gedankenfluss
hier es später am abend ich bin erkältet
so vaters setzte weitere 4 44 ja hier
ist jeder 3 wie könnt ihr auch
theoretisch was mir gerade aufhält so
komische wasser flüsse machen und dann
werden die dar eingeschwemmt das war
witzig nur dafür brauchen wir halt eine
menge wasser und da hätte ich lieber
gerne einen stadt ein einmal irgendwie
mehrere und dann müssen wir das ja auch
noch ganz in der weite bauen und da hat
man dann ganz ganz ganz ganz lange daran
zu setzen
obwohl kommt darauf an wie viele steine
man hat oder ich muss ganz für steine
farben und so weiter und wieder nacht
nicht acht schon bock hat mein handy
denkt hier auf einem nach dem anderen
mal ne weil das ist immer so wir haben
so eine tolle gruppe dort werden noch
ganz ganz viel stone das schreiben auf
jeden fall
wir haben so eine gruppe das habt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch in eurer stufe wo
man sich dann immer so bei facebook
schreibt so etwas hatten wir in dem und
dem fach auf hart kommt nach einer
klausur dran und eigentlich ist es so
wenn man lernen wir für eine klausur
oder dann einfach so durch den schultag
torkelte sich irgendwelche hausaufgaben
aufzuschreiben oder so kann man einfach
in die gruppe gucken und die andere
erledigen das fallen
das ist ganz cool aber handy bringt halt
immer auf welche komisches facebook
private des 16 das sind 5 wie sind sie
mal hier zu wenig das schwarze schaf der
ganzen seiten hier
der nabu
übrigens was ich euch auch sagen kann
beziehungsweise schon mal versprechen
kann
bald wird wieder einmal einen minecraft
kurzfilmen kommen
ich hab den letzten film der letzte film
war glaube ich in lommel dane minecraft
oder es war olaf ahrens am diamond und
unfall ihr also eine lava und an einer
von den beiden war der letzte kurs ich
glaube es war noch mal der in minecraft
und zwar habe ist er auch schon
irgendwie fünf sechs monate her und
seitdem habe ich mir ganz viele mode
zusammengesuchten team sage ich mal mit
dem ich das jetzt alles immer aufnehmen
und da wird auf jeden fall noch was
kommen also einen kurzfilm einfach
erwartet da nicht zuviel kurzfilm ist
für 23 minuten kommt drauf an wie lang
das wird und ich denke es wird euch alle
freuen
ich denke aber es dauert noch ein bis
zwei monate nicht einfach weil die
produktion davon so lange dauert sondern
ganz einfach weil wir erst mal zeit
finden müsst ich muss mich noch genau
gedanken über die story machen musik
wahl und alles mögliche das noch immer
so ein paar faktoren die eine rolle
spielen
und ich denke dann sollte das bald
erledigt sein also dann habe ich den
wald halt hochland und naja könnte euch
halt schon mal drauf freuen